uh so maybe i'll get started and so
we'll go in the order in which talks
appear in the proceedings
and uh
i think
okay paul is giving the talk not me okay
so uh yeah so sorry about the errors
yeah so neither of you responded to the
emails i wasn't sure who was uh
yeah so anyway so uh
uh yeah so we have five talks in this
session and each will be for about 10
minutes
and uh so the
the talks we'll do them in the order
that they appear in the
in the schedule the first talk will be
on sublinear time and space algorithms
for correlation clustering and chiang
wang from rutgers will speak about this
work
and then we have this uh talk about
sparse boolean factorizations of
matrices this is by ruiz zhang and
this is with a joint work with uh like
sitanchen zhao song and a bunch of
others
and the next two talks uh will be uh
somewhat related i think from uh from
what
what i can tell and so yeah one is uh
multi-valid learning and uh that will be
given by georgie nowaro
and uh
we have omni predictors
talked by parikshith who's uh the nice
introductory slide as we saw
okay and the final talk will be given by
paul and uh it will be on subgaussian
mean estimation in very high dimensions
okay so uh yeah so without further ado
maybe we can get started and uh so be
sure that this uh i mean if we stick to
about 10 minutes per talk we should have
some time for
maybe a question after every talk
so i'll be monitoring the
chat
and
so just for the speakers i might
just
like raise my hand if i see some
questions in the chat
but we won't interrupt you during the
talk so unless it's something super
urgent uh so we'll just wait till the
end of the talk okay so hope that makes
sense so that said
uh yeah so let's uh let's welcome the
first speaker chen wong of red cars
okay uh
i can stop sharing and
share
good
so you can see my screen right so it
doesn't
good okay let's get started
so hi everyone today i'll be talking
about our recent results on some linear
time and space algorithm for
coordinating clustering and this is a
joint work with my divider separation
groups
so to begin with let me motivate the
problem and give you the definitions so
uh this is a machine learning problem so
it has like real world applications so
suppose you are given documents okay
like it is documents and these documents
are either similar or dissimilar think
about each pair of them on some topics
for example i have these three documents
first of all usd action second value for
champions league and third by climate
change summit
the goal is to find a clustering that
puts similar documents together and this
is similar with the part okay for
example among these three documents
you're going to put the first and third
together they are similar more or less
about politics third second one about
sports so the standalone puts me a
separate cluster
so formally in correlation cloud stream
we are usually giving a liberal graph g
so as conventional v and vertices and e
set of edges
so in fact we are dealing with a
complete graph that means for each pair
of vertices there is an edge
and each edge is labeled as either
negative or positive okay for example if
i give you this graph it says five
vertices there's a positive energy let
me two negative naturally three would be
four and so on so forth
so you're only very interested in
minimizing disagreement cost so what
does it mean so suppose we are
implementing the clustering as shown in
the picture but there are two types of
edges we are going to charge costs the
first one is positive edges across
different clusters for example this v2v4
you can think of they are similar
documents but in the diff different
clusters the second one is this
negativity inside the same cluster for
example this v3 before you can think of
them as the dissimilar documents but in
the same cluster
okay
so more formally we are just going to
enumerate all of such pairs that they
share a positive edge but in different
clusters plus this
share negative edge bring the same
clusters
sum of the sum them up counts them and
then this is a total disagreement cost
and our goal is to minimize the total
discrete cost
okay
so let me tell you something about state
of the fair and our contributions
so there are some there are some
classical results about this correlation
clustering we know the exact solution is
in behind so the best polynomial time
approximation gives a 2.06 approximation
with some linear programming techniques
so there is a combinatorial algorithm
called pivot algorithm achieved 3
approximation
but polynomial time algorithm is not the
end of the story because in more than
massive data applications so sometimes
even storing or reading the entire input
itself is prohibitively expensive so we
need to deal with these like sublinear
algorithms which works with resources
substantially smaller than even the
inputs them themselves
so there's a quest for some linear
algorithm for correction clustering
so we study both the subnear time and
space algorithm so for the linear time
regime before it works best known
results in this local correlation
classroom algorithm by bonchai at all
which they showed that you can achieve
like three ops plus absolute square
approximation in order of n over
absolute square time giving the energy
distance
okay so there is an absolute n square
additive error and this seems inherent
because they also prove a lower bound
saying that if you're only allowed small
and square time there exists this small
constant c and epsilon such that we
cannot do better than c opt plus
absolute square
okay so we need a new model if we want
some linear time for purely
multiplicative approximation and we use
this uh positives of graph g plus in our
work so our first result basically
starts with this problem so we showed
that there exists a little time
algorithm find the constant
approximation for
a corrosion cluster with high
probability in order of analog square
time okay if given the positives of
graphs are changes this is almost a
quadratic improvement
and we also studied some linear space
coordination clustering so we studied
this with the graph streaming models
under these smaller vertices are given
in the beginning edges arrived once
another stream
so for example if you have five vertices
in the beginning there are only vertices
t equals one this positive attribute for
v5 arrives t equals to the negative
energy remember for rights and so on and
so forth
okay so a streaming algorithm ideally
only works with their single pass and
this increase came with memories
smaller than the worst case input size
and the dreamland scenario is this
semi-stream memory order of n poly log n
so also notice the o tilde n so which is
usually the memory necessary to output
the answers themselves
there are some algorithms that achieve
constant approximation with all
testosterone memory before but all of
them request more than one path and
before we work there's no known
algorithm with more than that but uh
with the single pass that the chief's
constant approximation so our second
contribution is basically to start off
these problems we give a single path
streaming algorithm with high
probability find the constant
approximation for question clustering
with the order of n log and edge space
but this is almost optimal
so the next four or five minutes i'm
going to talk on a high level our
algorithm will not show
so
the earliest of linear algorithms
usually simulates the keyword algorithm
which is very elegant and it essentially
computes a
maximal independent set on the positive
graph however there's a quadratic
barrier if you want to compute it is a
linear time given the initialness all
over a single path of the stream
okay
so very recently this elegant work by
coherently achieves the constant
approximation in six passes but didn't
use the pivot idea
so i won't dive into the algorithm but
if you trust me if i give you a graph
like something like this it has some
densely connected components and some
rather standalone vertices they will put
these density kinetic components in in
the same clusters and stand alone
vertices apart
so in other words their algorithm
implicitly they didn't do a
decomposition but the implicitly divides
the graph into density kinetic
components and vertices with sparse edge
connections
so we observe that this kind of
deposition is not first of the time it's
kind
there is exist this graph parses
decomposition first studied in the graph
serialization more recently in the uh
distributed streaming graph coloring
so what does it do so roughly speaking
it partitions the vertices into two
classes almost clicks and sparse
vertices so almost clicks are the
vertices that densely connected with
each other and their degrees are high so
for let's say like around the maximum
degree delta and for vertices you cannot
join any almost click there are spots
vertices so for example if i give you
this graph
i will mark the red vertices and almost
clicks because they are densely
connected with each other and their
degrees are high and the light blue
vertices adds the sparse vertices okay
and now we can just do collision
classroom by this strategy we can
decompose on the positives of graph g
plus and put for each almost click we
put here you know separate classroom for
each part vertex we put as a single tail
so we have this kind of strategy and for
example on the graph i showed you before
we will just place the classroom
clustering as shown in the picture
okay so we have this kind of we give a
graph we find this percentage position
and do quotient classrooms
but now this is not the end of the story
because there are some problems with the
canonical graph sparse decomposition the
first problem is only works on with the
maximum degree delta this creates a
problem because if you look at the graph
this this this is a three click but it
will because these degrees are lows you
are like decomposing sparse vertices and
use a lot of costs
so there is this version of loop called
a graph boston decomposition but along
the saudi which admits a local version
of decomposition which means for this
like local click it's it'll also
recognize that as almost click
but there are many pro there's some
several problems to just use their uh
their paper and one of the problem is
that their their work emphasizes on the
existence of such decomposition and it's
not clear if there are some linear
timelines with algorithms to find them
so in this work we basically like design
a new decomposition that requires order
of n logans at some point with high
probability and we can find the
decomposition in order of n log squared
time
and we further prove that these samples
can be
obtained in order of unlock and time
with the positive energy solutions all
others unlock an edge space you know
every single password stream
okay so they are not sure we basically
did this and now we can collect the same
holes in something like time or space
under the respective model
run in order of analog square and time
and find the decomposition and do the
curve to the classroom in order for
enhancement space
okay and that's that's basically our
algorithm there are some open problems
the first problem is right now our
approximation factor constant is large
is 10 to the fifth to ten to the sixth
so if we want to like reduce the
constant so what can we do and is there
a lower bound and we we believe that our
algorithm works much better in the worst
case guarantee in real-world
applications we can test empirical
performance and the final thing is that
so another interesting problem is it has
the optimal value for correlation
classroom without output the clarity
clustering itself in very small speeds
let's say polylog
so for more detail please check our
longer talk and thank you for attention
thanks a lot jen this is a very good
talk and right on time
so uh so does anyone have like quick
questions for chen while uh i think ruiz
said some
it's not i i mean i just had one very
quick question like your algorithm does
it use only like uh single pass through
the data or uh does the sampling and
these other steps do they do you require
different passes for them no no no no
you can you can do like i think it's
just simple yeah all of them simpler but
not that easy like
it's it's it's doable and it needs some
like a modification for the rather
simpler
yeah
yeah
okay so if you can stop sharing i think
you is confirmed
thank you
all right yeah yeah we see your slide so
the next talk is uh given by ruiz sang
from ut austin he's talking about
sparse boolean matrix factorization and
some of the application okay
okay uh hello everyone i'm going to talk
about symmetric sparse boolean matrix
factorization is a joint work with
sanction and joseon and yunjo tao
so let's get started from an old problem
it's called non-negative matrix
factorization
here's the definition of amf so you are
giving an n by m matrix m and also a
graph parameter r you are asked to find
an n by r
non-negative matrix w1 and
m by our non-negative matrix w2 such
that the in their products w1 times w2
transpose and uh and ends the distance
is minimized and so for this old problem
it has many different applications in
many different areas
more recently there are some variants of
the nmf problem so the first kind of the
variant is called the symmetric nmf
which requires the two factors w1 and w2
are equal
for this problem is related to the
kernel kines and also related to the
graph clustering problem
another variant of nmf is called the
binary value in mmf where in this
setting the w1 and w2 can only take
values in some
binary set like zero or one or plus
minus one
for binary value in mmf it has some
applications in coding theory and also
in like graph particular and boolean
factor analysis
a third variant of nmf is called the
sparse mf where the w1 and w2 are
required to be some sparse matrices
and in this work we consider the the nmf
problem with all of these three kind of
additional uh constituents
which is a sparse symmetric boolean
matrix factorization or denoted as ss
bmf problem
so here's the more formal definition of
ssbmf so you are giving a symmetric
matrix and in the early dimension m by n
and also two parameters k and r so you
are asked to find an n by r boolean
matrix w success if u of w has exactly k
ones and you you you are asked to
minimize the number of different entries
between m and the ww transfers
and we we discovered that this problem
turns out to have many natural
motivations from theoretical computer
science and machine learning
the first motivation is about click
decomposition so
if we regard the given matrix m as the
arguments matrix of a graph key then the
vector w will encode will encode a click
power of key which partitions the edges
of the graph into
several clicks and the space they
constituent becomes the conclusion that
each vertex of the graph belongs to
exactly quickly and this is an example
so this problem also helpful in
analyzing the social network
and another motivation comes from the
combinatorics so if we regard the
factor matrix w as an incidence matrix
of a k uniform hyper graph here the k u
uniform have a graph means each hyperx
contains exactly
k vertices and then the
given input matrix m is the adjacency
matrix of the line graph of h where the
each hyper edge corresponds to one
vertex in the half in the line graph of
the hypergraph and the two half edges
are connected in the line graph if and
only if these hyper edges
overlap in the hyper graph
in this setting the ssbmf problem just
asks for reconstructing the original
hypergraph giving its line graph
and this is also an
old problem in combinatorics when k
equals to 2 which corresponds to the
graph case this problem is easy and we
already have many nearly linear time
algorithm to solve the language
reconstruction problem however when k is
large this problem turns out to be np
hard and it also implies the worst case
hardness of ssbmf problem
basically if you assume p naught equal
to np then you cannot hope to exactly
solve the ssbnf problem in polynomial
time
and the third motivation comes from the
security of machine learning
so instahyde is a recently proposed
scheme for privacy tuning your networks
on images roughly speaking
it constructs
each synthetic public tuning image using
random linear combinations of k privacy
images and the security of instant hype
is an important pro is an important
problem and some attacks on this scheme
has been proposed
and we observe that a case step of this
these attacks can be exactly formulated
as an ssbmf problem
and it implies that this attacking
algorithm implies the average case
algorithm for ssbmf and why these are
average case because each synthetic
image is generated from a random linear
combination of k
images
however these algorithms are either
heuristic or only work for certain
parameters and we hope to obtain a more
general and provable every case or
reason for ssbms
and this is our first main result we
provide a
we propose every case algorithm for
ssbms
so
let me first
state the distribution assumption of our
algorithm so we assume that each row of
the ground truth w is an independent
uniformly random case bar spooling
vector and the given input and just
equals to w times w transpose here w is
the ground truth
and the matrix multiplication is over
the boolean semi unit
then we prove that as long as m is large
enough we can efficiently and exactly
recover
the
factor matrix w up to a permutation and
the going time is just m to the omega
plus one here omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent
as a quality
our average case ssbmf algorithm can be
used to solve the so-called base k
vector sound problem
so this problem is the generalization of
the
famous uh k sound problem and it's also
a mathematical abstraction of the
instant height attacking
so as you can see the u the famous k
sound problem is a special case of this
bkwa sound problem with the dimension d
equals to 1 and the probability vector
m also equals to 1.
and we prove that
under some distribution assumptions we
can recover the heavy coordinates of
each hidden vectors x1 to xr very
efficiently
and also in our paper we through a worst
case guarantee for the ssbmf although in
the worst case the exact working of ssb
and mfa and bihar for an absolute
approximate working of ssbmf we gave a
question polynomial time algorithm
we use a
2 csp solver to guess this worst case
algorithm
so now let me talk about a few open
questions about sparse symmetrically
matrix factorization the first open
question is about the worst case
approximated ssbimf
so can we improve our
algorithm that baselines to csp solver
so for example can we give a fixed
framework tries to explore algorithm
based once in time and polynomial end
but some functions in other parameters
or can we use this possibility by
proving the hardness of approximation
for ssbms in the
worst case
and and the second open question is
about the best k vector sound problem
in our paper we discovered that it has
some applications in machine learning
security can we find more
cryptographic applications of best key
vector sound and also have improved the
average case hardness of best k vector
sound problem
that's all thank you
thanks a lot princess uh
good talk and thanks for sticking to the
time as well so any questions for uh
while uh maybe you can stop sharing
maybe georgie can start setting up but
meanwhile any questions
about your open questions like do you uh
like
for all you know additive approximation
could be possible efficiently right or
can you rule that out also from your
hardnesses
uh no way
even for the additive approximation we
only have a question for normal time but
we cannot get a purely polynomial time
algorithm
but we can also we currently do not know
how to prove the hardness of even for
the additive approximation
all right so uh yeah so if there any
other questions feel free to keep typing
the
yeah one thing i forgot to mention is
that for those of you are in the
audience uh
you can feel free to type questions for
any of the speakers so some of them have
agreed to hang around after the session
so they might answer
uh after we are done okay so hopefully
we'll do that
and
so let's go ahead and start the next
talk so this is online multi-valid uh
learning and the speaker is georgie now
uh nuero from upenn
right
thanks uh yeah this is joined work with
a bunch of awesome people as upenn and
rice um they're in gupta is young molesh
pines one of my advisors aaron roth
and um just at a glance um basically
what we do is we obtain uncertainty
uh guarantees
um that are with respect to a
potentially
large collection of
sub spaces of the sample space so you
can think of it as predicting something
about individuals and uh we want to be
confident when predicting uh something
about them on all these specified
subpopulation groups essentially and our
technique is interesting in its own
right it's a simple and
general game theoretic tool and
hopefully we'll go over it briefly
okay so first of all why should we care
about uncertain guarantees well
traditionally of course
building and training accurate models
has been the predominant line of
research in machine learning but of
course uh it is very important that
um these models are also confident in
what they're predicting
and uh of course uh conditional
guarantees would be the strongest type
of guarantees so imagine um for a
certain individual x uh predicting
um a prediction interval just for that
individual so the probability that the
label of that individual falls into
um our interval would be 95 conditional
on that x but such things are typically
impossible in rich feature spaces and so
um instead
you might consider marginal guarantees
so your prediction rule would be
95 valid over the entire population uh
so pair is x comma y
um and another famous type of marginal
guarantee uh would be calibration so
um
basically labels should stay close to
what we are predicting
so um just a cartoon to keep in mind
maybe imagine a patient stops by the
doctor and the doctor looks at the
patient's teacher's ex and says okay um
here is my
diagnosis for you and here's my
confidence interval l of x u of x um and
the patient might wonder okay what kind
of confidence interval is that and the
doctor says it's a marginal prediction
interval
um but
this could be problematic so in
particular say the patient belongs to a
very small like less than five percent
uh sub-population group then it's a
ninety-five percent prediction level
right so it can like completely avoid
covering uh such a small sub-population
and so in our work we basically give
stronger than marginal uncertainty
guarantees in the sense that um
we
can be given any arbitrarily larger
complex potentially overlapping family
of population groups and we'll make sure
that each of these groups has its own
uncertain guarantee
and additionally we'll assume basically
nothing about the data so we'll work in
an online adversarial setting and so
that covers potential application
domains such as time series data so uh
all sorts of correlates covariates
shifts label shifts strategic effects
compare this to some other important
answering quantification frameworks like
conformal prediction where you can often
make assumptions like in change
exchangeability so like only slightly
weaker than iid
so um our setting you can imagine uh
being as follows so uh we have an
adversary and the adversary gives us at
each day from one to t a patient and
only tells us the features of that
patient but doesn't tell the conditional
label distribution of that patient and
we only observe this context so the
features and then we make one out of you
know three possible types of predictions
that's what we consider in this paper we
can predict the mean of that label
distribution we can predict maybe the
cave moment say like variance of um that
label or we can predict uh and 95
confidence interval and so once only
once we've committed to such a
prediction do we actually observe the
realized label for
that individual the current round
and so um yeah as an example we'll
consider a mean multi-calibration here
very briefly so
um as a general introduction
multicalibration basically says
that you should be
calibrated on each group in this like
potentially large collection of groups
where calibration means that whenever
you predict
uh roughly
um you know something so our predictions
will be in zero one so if we predict i
over n then on those days the average
true label should also be like i over n
and we can represent it formally by
considering these like quantities vgis
so for each group and for each of these
like
small buckets that our prediction could
fall into we want um our prediction on
those rounds where the patient belongs
to group g and we predict roughly iveren
to be close to the true label
and we say that the learner is alpha and
multicalibrated if we have these n
buckets and
the maximum of the absolute values of
these v quantities is small
so that's like our objective here and
notice it's not really as smooth so it's
not going to be very easy to handle it
so instead we'll switch to this softmax
circuit loss so actually a very close
approximation to the maximum of these
calibration violations which is what we
really care about uh but it's a very
close caliber it's very close matched to
this actual objective so what this gives
us is that we can now use like a
tailor-looking balance to essentially
say um the increment in this loss
between any two consecutive rounds
will only depend uh on this quantity so
that depends on kind of like the
difference between the true label and
what we end up predicting in that round
and if all of these increments are small
then we can bound uh the overall loss at
the last round by a telescoping argument
and so let's make the learner greedy so
at each round the learner will play uh
mu t the predicted mean so as to make
this increment small only at this round
doesn't care about any future ends
and so our framework basically says okay
let's imagine uh this interaction as a
two player zero sum game where the
objective that the learner wants to make
small the adversary wants to make large
is this bound on the current rounds
increments
and so it looks like the learner is
handicapped because you have to first
choose your prediction and then the
adversary says what the true thing was
but actually the minimax theorem says
you can flip the order so
uh we can consider the car factual world
where we knew what the true label was of
course then we can get close to it so we
can be multi-calibrated and the minimax
theorem allows us to actually
come up with a so-called minimax
strategy right that achieves this
closeness even though we are actually
going first not second and then we can
unwrap this and get the bound on the
surrogate loss and then get the bound of
the multi-calibration loss cool and so
we get these types of guarantees uh like
one of a root t multi calibration
guarantee and um
this is uh optimal even in the
distributional world uh and so how do we
obtain this uh actually algorithmically
well we can so here's the algorithm the
only takeaway from this slide should be
that it's actually a very simple
algorithm so in principle to compute the
minimax option strategy for each round
we need to kind of solve like a linear
program but we don't need to do that
here so we can like simplify it into
just computing some quantities based on
our past performance and then predicting
um sort of either one point or actually
randomized over just two points it's
also a very low randomization which is
good
okay and so prediction intervals kind of
follow in a very similar fashion uh
essentially we can define quantities
that will say okay uh for each uh
individual from like each group um we
want our coverage to be close to someone
when it's delta i think 0.95 and then
once again we can define prediction
interval multiplicity by saying that the
maximum of the absolute values of these
quantities expressing coverage on all
these groups are bounded by uh some
alpha
and we know the drill now we just switch
to soft max loss with respect to these
quantities bound to one step differences
consider a zero sum game that uh has the
balance on these differences as the
objective and let the learners sort of
play the minimax strategy the algorithm
here is a bit more complicated it
actually requires us to solve a gigantic
linear program but we simplify it enough
to where uh it becomes polynomial time
we use the ellipsoid algorithm together
with some greedy maps like oracle to be
precise
so in conclusion this is like a general
technique for stronger than marginal
uncertainty guarantees in an online
setting with the adverse serial data
and we can obtain all these guarantees
uh using efficient algorithms which we
provide
and in fact
subsequently we discovered that this
parameter can be extended even more to
handle convex concave
vector losses and
it lets us actually obtain um many
useful online learning settings beyond
an uncertain estimation and for future
work um it shouldn't be too hard we
think to extend uh these results from
binary labels so like zero to one uh to
multi-label uh and from prediction
intervals to prediction sets a concept
studied widely in conformal prediction
theory let's say
also one of our algorithms as i
mentioned is efficient but not very
practical so maybe can we make it not
just polynomial time but also actually
fully functionable
and finally some experiment evaluation
of our algorithms would be good so do
they work better on distributional uh as
opposed to worst case adversarial data
yeah that's it um yeah thanks very much
[Music]
someone has questions please please feel
free to ask
maybe you can stop sharing and then
parikshit can start starting up in the
meantime so uh yeah if there are
questions uh
like i said also please type in the chat
will be fine too
oh my gosh here yeah let's see why
can you hear me other thing
yes we can and yeah can you see my
slides
uh yes we can yeah so the next uh talk
is on omni predictors it's not closely
related to the previous talk so uh
pariksit uh mr speaker yeah please go
ahead
yeah uh thanks everyone for coming and
this is of joint work with many
wonderful co-authors adam kalai omar
rheingold watson sharon and odi weeder
now i'm sure this first slide is
entirely explanatory but since i have 10
minutes i'll tell you what omni
predictors are
so we're all familiar with the loss
minimization paradigm which is the
dominant paradigm currently in machine
learning for training a model
the paradigm goes something like this
you have a loss function l
and then you have a class of models
maybe decision trees or deep neural
networks
and then
in order to learn what you do is you try
and find the
model in this class which minimizes the
expected loss under the target
distribution that you care about
so this is a very general paradigm it's
been tremendously successful
but at the same time it's not everything
we've come to realize that there are
certain limitations especially with
regard to desiderata like privacy and
fairness
in this talk we are going to
ask a different question
it's again about the limitations of this
model we're going to ask
what do you do if you're not sure up
front what loss function to optimize for
right
so naturally you might wonder well why
should we care about this question
and secondly our whole way of thinking
about learning is so tied to loss
minimization that it's not even clear
that the question that i've framed makes
sense right for instance in clustering
we know that
the question of finding mean versus
finding median can be phrased as
optimizing different kinds of loss
functions
so now if i don't even tell you what
loss function i care about what are you
expected to do
okay
so let's talk about why this question is
interesting
there might be many situations where
upfront we do not know what the correct
loss function to minimize this
or it might be the case where there are
multiple loss functions which are of
interest to us and we really want one
model that works for all these loss
functions
or it might be that you know the data we
have right now at some point we'll also
learn what the loss function is but we
don't it may not be at the same time as
when we have the data to train right
like consider something like a medical
scenario where the cost of mistakenly
prescribing aspirin to someone is very
different from the cost of saying do
some kind of invasive surgery and
getting that wrong right
so
when you have a situation like this
the loss minimization paradigm it
doesn't necessarily give you a very
satisfactory answer
even when the losses in question are all
nice and convex
you could have a different optimal for
each loss
and in general to get provable
guarantees at least you need to retrain
from scratch every time now of course
using things like transfer learning you
could argue well no it's not really from
scratch but there's no probable
guarantee saying okay you optimize for
this thing then you're halfway or more
there to optimizing for some other loss
which might be very different because
as this picture which i'm not going to
have time to explain tells you there's
the geometry of the space could be such
that different losses are optimized at
very different points in the space right
this is a real problem there's a bunch
of heuristics out there which will
minimize for certain losses like l2
squared loss or some other truthful loss
function and then they just pretend like
these are the ground truth probabilities
and you hope for the best right
the question here is whether we can do
something better
okay
so this it sounds like a problem which
is crying out for a definition and that
is the main conceptual contribution of
this work is this notion of an omni
predictor which we think of as one
predictor to rule them on
so the setup here is that you have a
family of loss functions
loss functions they take a zero one
label which is the true outcome
they take a prediction which let's say
it's a real value and then they assign a
loss to you if the label is zero you
predict this here's your loss if it's
one and you predict this there's your
notes right
and then there is a hypothesis class c
given this set up an lc omnipredictor
it's just a function which takes each
point and predicts probabilities in 0 1
such that for any loss in this class
there exists a simple post-processing
function this post for a sync function
doesn't look at the data which could be
very high dimensional it only looks at
the prediction that you make and gives
you a real value
the guarantee we have is that for any
loss in the class for any loss in l the
expected loss we suffered by
post-processing f
is less than the expected loss compared
to anything in c and this includes the
best hypothesis which is probably
optimized to this particular loss
function
so this is a lot to unpack we want to
learn this predictor once and for all
that just predicts probabilities
just by post-processing these
probabilities
in a way that's specific to the loss we
can do better than anything in c
this is the goal that we've set okay
now why is this even
possible why is this not a null notion
it's because if you had something called
the base optimal predictor which just
predicts the conditional value of the
label given a point x
it is folklore and easy to show that
this is an omni predictor no matter what
l is no matter what c is
what this means is that if you know the
probabilities the optimal probabilities
the right probabilities of the label for
every point you can always make
predictions which are optimal not just
an expectation but even point wise
optimum right
and this post-processing is the easy
part the hard part is that computing
this base optimal it's information
theoretically and computationally
impossible
so the question really is whether we can
compute this notion of omnipredictors
efficiently for meaningful choices of l
and c
so this answer it requires a bit of
digression into the area of multi-group
fairness specifically this notion of
multi-calibration that yogi talked about
this was introduced introduced by
hebbert johnson
now up front i should say that this is a
notion of group fairness there is no
loss function in the definition right
calibration is a well-known motion a
predictor is calibrated if the expected
label condition on the prediction is the
prediction itself
multicalibration just asks for
calibration
conditioned on every sub-population from
a large class c that you care about
right
so this c in their work it's meant to
capture sub-populations that we wish to
protect in our work it's a hypothesis
class so we extend this definition in a
way that allows you to think about real
valued function c and so on
and
this notion let's just say that this
hebert johnson it all showed that it's
efficiently computable
given a certain learning primitive for
the class c
so this brings us to our main theorem
which says that if the predictor f is
multi-calibrated for the class c
then it is an lc omni predictor
where l is the class of all convex lip
sheets loss functions
okay so you just take the outcome of
this predictor you post-process it
you're competitive with any hypothesis
from the class c the post-processing
depends on the loss but nothing else
does
this means you can really train all it
you know the training can be done
independent of the loss all you have to
know is that i'm interested in a convex
loss function you can train when the
loss is revealed to you you can post
process the predictions
and the post processing here is exactly
the same as what you do if you knew the
bayes optimal predictor so it's very
simple
you need the class l of loss functions
to be convex this liciousness condition
we can relax it a little we don't need
it to be lift shifts everywhere but this
theorem it includes lp losses logistic
laws exponential laws basically every
loss function that i am aware of is
covered by this theorem
so now um why is this interesting well
this has this good karma interpretation
multi-calibration is a fairness notion
the authors swear to me that they
weren't thinking about loss minimization
when they came up with this yet it gives
you this incredibly strong loss
minimization guarantee that we don't
know how to get otherwise right
and
one interesting contribution here is a
new view of what multi-calibration
should mean i'll just tell you what this
view is and then wind up right we think
of multi-calibration as the partition of
the input space which satisfies the
following pseudorandomness property
within each partition
for everything in c the expectation of
cx times y is the product of the
expectations so it's almost as though c
and y are independent conditioned on a
partition
and now from this getting a predictor is
very easy within each partition you just
predict the expected label
so the intuition here is that the real
process which is going on it looks as
though within each partition points are
just flipping coins with different
biases and deciding their label right
this is just intuition but there is a
way to formalize this using the outcome
indistinguishability framework of our
guitar
so in summary what we are proving here
is that multi-calibration gives us a
very strong loss minimization guarantee
this relies on a new view of
multi-calibration itself as a partition
which i think is independently
interesting
it gives us a way to define learning
without a loss function more in the
sense of a structure versus randomness
decomposition
there's a lot of rich connections to
work in agnostic learning which was done
about 15 years ago but it turns out to
connect very closely to this notion of
multi-calibration
it points out some interesting contrast
with multi accuracy it's a notion which
i haven't defined so i won't be able to
tell you more about this
in terms of future directions i think
the most pressing future direction is
that multi-calibration is this really
nice notion from a fairness and now also
from an optimization viewpoint
the sample complexity to achieve it is
really high
it gets worse when you're doing
multi-class classification but it's
exponentially the number of classes that
you care about
there are some works which attempt to
remedy this and they come up with
relaxed notions which don't have such
high sample complexity but i think this
is still a very interesting direction
for work
so i'll stop right there thank you very
much
well thanks a lot felicia it was a great
talk and uh
any questions
from the
audience
any fellow speakers
so uh yes i think paul is here so can
you share your stream okay yeah
all right so i think the last uh
speaker of the session is
paul valiant he will talk about optimal
sub gaussian mean estimation very high
dimensions
so there is one question for pariksit we
can come to it right after or maybe
you're typing an answer so that's great
okay
all right so paul uh go ahead
okay great um thank you um
so sorry uh can you hear me
okay um
optimal sub gaussian mean estimation in
very high dimensions um so i'm paul
valiant this is joint work with jasmine
so today i'm going to tell you about two
problems
the first one is the classic problem of
statistics of mean estimation given
samples from today a very high
dimensional distribution we want to
estimate its mean as well as is possible
given our data
more on this in a moment the second
problem which i want to tell you about
which at first glance seems rather
different is that of coming out with
good tail bounds
so here um suppose you have the sum of
independent bounded random vectors with
some total covariance
how can you come up with a high
probability bound on the distance l2
distance of the sum from its mean
in other words we're seeking a vector
analog of the bernstein inequality
so um a guiding idea here is
that in some sense the most interesting
thing to me about high dimensional
gaussians is that as the dimension
increases these gaussians start looking
more and more like a spherical shell
so
to give you a uh illustration of this
so if you look at the distribution of
the length of a gaussian
standard gaussian random variable indeed
d dimensions normalized by uh
one over d
in one dimension
um
the distribution of length doesn't look
like much it's just half the gaussian
but as the dimension increases you can
see that the uh length starts adhering
more and more tightly to a spherical
shell in this case at radius one
and the the challenge is to try to
capture this with the tailbone
um previous tail bounds um in some sense
don't capture this spherical shell
behavior very well and one way of saying
this is that
spherical um previous tailbones in some
sense apply for all dimensions without
um improving with the dimension so
because there's two uniform with respect
to the dimension they fail to adhere
titrant title to sphere as the dimension
increases
so this is the second challenge that
we're going to talk about today
um okay so to go back to the main mean
estimation problem
so again this is one of the most
important problems in statistics given
data how do you estimate the mean of the
underlying distribution this also shows
up as a subroutine of various
computational processes
um
but
um it's also one of the most important
primitives of real-world data analysis
so supposing you've got some expensive
experiment that's producing some data
um i'll illustrate it just in one
dimension
um so if you have collected these eight
data data points um
how do you estimate the mean of the
underlying process
well returning the sample mean is a very
sensible thing to do
um and if your distribution is a
gaussian or something well-behaved the
sample mean behaves extremely well
but what if you continue collecting data
and you get maybe
some sample point extremely far to the
right
what do you do do you take it seriously
do you throw it out
what if you get two data points
um so how do we view this
algorithmically
so if two out of our 10 data points are
outliers
well this is in some sense compatible
with a different truth where the
expected number of outliers we should
have seen is maybe as low as 1 10 as
high as 4 tenths
and algorithmically in some sense what
we're trying to capture is we're trying
to understand one of the most extreme
distributions that could have led to the
observed data
and then we want to return an estimate
that's accurate enough
to be compatible with all such
distributions that could have led to our
observed data
however if we see two out of ten
outliers maybe we just got really
unlucky maybe we should have seen point
zero zero zero one outliers and we just
got unlucky so you know it's one in a
million unlikely to see two out of 10
outliers if the true probability is this
but you know whether our algorithm is
allowed to throw out the scenario or
whether our algorithm must take it
seriously it depends on
the desired confidence of our our answer
so if we even if we want our algorithm
to be correct
except with error 10 to minus 6 then we
do need to take this possibility
seriously
so okay
the goal of mean estimation given
samples from some distribution we want
to estimate its mean to within distance
epsilon with probability 1 minus delta
namely we want to understand the optimal
trade-off between these three parameters
the number of samples n the accuracy
epsilon and the constant delta
today i'm going to focus on the high
dimensional case where dimensionality
we'll look at in terms of what's called
the effective dimension um very standard
quantity which is the ratio of the trace
of the covariance to the maximal
variance in any direction
the effective dimension behaves exactly
as you would like so for distributions
with a spherical covariance it just
counts the number of dimensions of the
sphere
some distributions have covariance that
looks more like a pancake and here the
effect of dimension essentially counts
the number of big dimensions of the
pancake
and
exactly the regime of effective
dimension that our result applies to it
is here
so okay how do we get started on this
problem well the ideal case for mean
estimation is when the distribution is
extremely well behaved like a gaussian
and for gaussian the provably optimal
thing to do is to return the sample mean
so
it's good to ask
how well does this work
um so given the gaussian of some
covariance how well does the sample mean
work at estimating the variance so sorry
at actually we're trying to the true
mean
um
so
as we've described um
gaussians have this spherical shell
behavior in high dimensions
where
the
error of this estimate is going to be
extremely close one plus level of one
times this radius of this spherical
shell where the radius depends on the
trace of the covariance
so gaussians the error for gaussian mean
estimation behaves like a spherical
shell
the question is what can we do in
general so we're going to have an
unknown distribution with unknown
covariance and we need to design an
algorithm we want to design an algorithm
that tries to emulate this
and the main result is that we will do
this um provided
and is efficiently large
so we're we're going to come up with an
algorithm that for any distribution is
going to emulate the
spherical shell performance of gaussians
um okay so there's lots of prior work on
mean estimation
um including um a lot of recent work on
mean estimation
including a lot of one-dimensional a lot
of work on the even the one-dimensional
case um so my co-author jasper lee is
presenting what we hope is a combination
of this line of work next week at fox um
but so in the high dimensional case this
is a brief description of some recent
results um
and i'm using the slide just to point
out that this problem
is daunting
um so it took until surprisingly
recently 2019 to get any kind of
algorithm even an exponential time
algorithm that is constant factor sample
optimal
so it's taking a lot of work to
improve the computational complexity and
even from especially the sample
complexity um if you look under the hood
some of these factors are as big as a
trillion
um by contrast today i'm going to tell
you about
a linear time algorithm which is one
plus little of one optimal in terms of
sample complexity and it's extremely
simple as
i trust you'll see
but at the cost that the algorithm only
works in very high dimensions
so okay as a motivation here
the good performance of the sample mean
for the gaussian case comes from from
the fact that in high dimensions
gaussians adhere to a spherical shell
so it's natural to ask can we extend
this these spherical shell tailbone
beyond gassing distributions
so we're going to start with um the
standard one-dimensional bernstein bound
which describes
if you have sums of independent random
variables that are bounded
sorry
the bernstein bound and sometimes
combines two kinds of information it
combines information about the variance
of these random variables with a bound r
on the support side of these random
variables
and the denominator here
has interaction between these two terms
showing essentially how gaussian bands
gracefully degraded in the presence of
outliers at a rate of r
so the new tail bound that we're
introducing generalizes this we think
very naturally to high dimensions
um so we have
sums of independent random vectors
each bounded by some radius r and then
our bound is on the
distance of the sum
um compared to the radius of the
spherical shell so what's the
probability that the distance of the
thumb is t more than the radius of the
spherical shell
and the probability that we find is
extremely similar to the bernstein bound
very natural generalization we think and
it's not hard to check that it
has a spherical shell behavior namely as
the as the effective dimension increases
this band adheres more and more tightly
to the spherical shell
so okay um the claim
in this talk is that this tailbone is
the crucial ingredient to coming up with
a simple algorithm so let me tell you
about that now so how do we use this
tool to give us a algorithm for mean
estimation
so this
tail bound applies for bounded
distributions how do we take a general
distribution and get a bounded
distribution from it
well trivially we can pick some ball of
radius r
and conditioned on samples being in this
ball
then
we come the samples come from a
bounded conditional distribution so we
can apply the theorem
um there's some delicacy to choosing the
right r
but given this the algorithm is
extremely simple so this is our final
algorithm which is the main result of
the paper
step one roughly estimate the mean with
classical coordinate wise median and
means algorithm
step two
um compute s in terms of the desired
confidence level delta
throw out the s for the samples from our
center of our ball that we've chosen and
return the mean of our return the mean
of what remains this is our algorithm
it's linear time
and this is the main result
um so just to end with um a brief
comment
um
contrasting this one plus little over
one factor type algorithm
with this tail bound the tail band we
think is
useful it's new but it's not quite one
plus level of one tight
so to draw a diagram of this
consider the probability distribution of
the mean estimation error
so the ground truth is going to adhere
very tightly to some spherical shell
and supposing instead we have a tail
band that bounds things less tightly
is this good enough well recall that the
overall goal is to understand for some
given confidence delta
what the delta probability tail of the
mean estimation error is
and the point is that even though the
red and the blue curves might be very
different in in the vertical direction
in the horizontal direction the ratio is
going to be one plus level of one
because both of them both the red and
the blue adhere extremely tightly to the
spherical shell and this is what gives
us our one plus little of one
algorithmic performance even when our
tail band is not one plus or one tight
in the probabilistic sense namely in the
vertical axis here so in summary
um
this notion that gaussians have behaved
like spherical shells in high dimensions
this is the intuition behind this paper
and the fact that we get a spherical
shell tail bound is the big wind that
gives us the rest of the paper given
this tail bound our algorithm is very
simple it works for simple robust
reasons
and we hope that um the simple and
robust implications of this tail bound
mean that the tailband might be useful
much more broadly
okay
so uh yeah so i had one quick question
like uh do you know if like this sort of
uh thing does not work in lower
dimensions do you really need the high
dimensionality
okay yeah um so
um
great question so one thing which i
skipped over um so this algorithm throws
out um the square of the log of the
robustness samples
so in the optimal 1d
algorithm that is just going to present
in fox next week we need to throw out
just a single log instead of a log
squared number of samples
so this discrepancy in some sense shows
how why this algorithm can't just
transparently extend to low dimensions
so um we don't think there's a low
dimension algorithm we think the
full problem of coming up with tight
analysis in the in for all dimensions
will involve significantly more work
um but the point is that um the
spherical shell behavior gives a very
easy analysis for a particular regime
namely the high dimensional regime
that's very cool
any other questions
i think we are almost at the end of our
time but
i think we have the room so if there are
questions
people ask i think there's one in the
chat paul i don't know if you can see
[Music]
uh uri asked do you expect a smooth
transition in the power of log one over
delta as the dimension grows
um yeah okay that's an interesting
question so the the
um
[Music]
the
algorithm here and the algorithm in one
dimension um in fox next week both sort
of can be represented as just throw out
a certain number of samples that are far
away
and this isn't the way that most
algorithms in this area look um
so most algorithms do something much
more complicated
um
so
the right hand to the optimal answer
might involve something rather more
nuanced um that maybe does rather
different things in different directions
so again in a very high dimensional
space there's many different directions
and you might want to treat samples that
are outliers in one direction
differently from samples that are
outliers in a different direction
so i think that might be where the
nuance lies instead of just picking
exactly the right number so i think the
final algorithm will actually be more
complicated than this but the reason
this paper i think is you know fits in
igcs is because the algorithm is simple
all right yeah so let's uh let's thank
all the speakers this was a great
session so uh thanks a lot for coming by
i know that uh
online conferences can be a little
explaining so thanks to the audience
also for making it so yeah thanks a lot
you